oh what the garlic and mayo
okay come on a few things make me
happier than chomping down on some dead
juicy delicious animals
and this unfortunately creates a
conflict between me and the vegan
activists so my producers have gathered
together the strongest arguments made by
the vegans on Tick Tock and we will see
if those arguments persuade me to give
up my beloved meat for now
vegans take it away it's vegan because
it's strawberry milk and not like cow
milk you know what I mean so please tell
me how you milk
strawberry
the same way that you milk an almond in
the same way that you milk an oat could
you milk me you probably need like
little tiny baby fingers to go get that
little cute Udders on the oats and you
just squeeze them and then you get the
milk out of it
yeah that's an obvious one next one
what's your favorite restaurant I'm
going to talk about all the time what do
you get at Taco Bell
I get a Crunchwrap but swap out the beef
and get some beans in there also swap
out the sour cream and the cheese
yeah don't they use eggs in their like
in their wraps
yeah I hope they don't either because
then that wouldn't be vegan
you're under arrest for veganity
violation I don't know why she was
coming at me I have seen vegan YouTubers
who like go to Taco Bells can make it
vegan just to show people that like it
can be like convenient I don't know why
you guys are trying to tell me
I eat honey but honey Isn't vegan did
you learn that at vegan Academy I can't
tell if she's extremely pro-vegan or if
she's actually trying to convince people
not to be vegan at all because this
isn't just a phenomenon that happens
with vegans this is true of any group
you will always have people who are more
Orthodox in that group than others who
are more rigorous and more disciplined
than others and so when when people are
more rigorous and Orthodox and
disciplined it's good for them to have a
spirit of Charity and patience and try
to bring others along but very often
what happens is you'll have the people
just become like uber cool super Purity
monsters who'll just insist that if you
in any way deviate from what they are
doing that that you're just a complete
degenerate refuse trash and that's what
she's doing there oh you
um you looked at a glass of milk once
yeah that's not vegan so it's a battle
between an extraordinarily unreasonable
person and an only semi-unreasonable
person that would be the kind of
moderate vegan
but I really like her because the effect
of her her snarkiness and arguments is
to show people that they're probably not
vegan and veganism might well be
impossible and there's really no reason
to be vegan
anyway I haven't really heard a good
argument to be vegan at all just all
these all these ways in which people
fall short okay next one so you actually
believe that
something ridiculous it'll be ridiculous
I'm sorry but you don't believe that
humans
made you an animal ask God try that I'm
sorry sorry where is this God and by the
way if God and the devil were in a room
with a baby lamb who would slit the baby
laugh throat I assume the devil
right or the lamb would lay down his
life for his friends as a sacrifice to
the father and then be resurrected on
the third day but she she made the error
from the beginning
and I guess the guy was not totally
precise in his language either which is
yes we're animals we're just a different
kind of animal human beings are animals
but we're rational animals
we have a rational Soul
we have will and intellect
we can
conceive of things in the abstract and
we can turn our will toward those things
rationally we don't just follow our
repetitive will we don't just follow our
base will we just follow our desires for
food or whatever but we also follow our
higher will and our our concept of
Justice the beasts can't have a concept
of Justice right now go to
grillblazer.com are you tired of waiting
ages for your grill to heat up well now
you can say goodbye to those tedious
moments of impatiently watching the
charcoal burn and say hello to instant
barbecue Perfection thanks to our new
friends over at Grill Blazer Grill
Blazers Grill guns are designed to do
everything from expertly searing your
Meats to lighting charcoal grills wood
stoves outdoor fireplaces and just about
anything you can think of
that you would need a high power fire
source to solve that problem
Grille Blazers offers two types of Grill
guns the grill gun basic is a high power
propane torch designed to Light charcoal
and wood grills and smokers burns up to
3 600 Degrees 30 inch flame for anything
you need a big bed torch to do and the
SUV gun has a shorter Barrel perfect for
professional Culinary Kitchen uses from
gently carbonizing brulee or other
sugars and fruits to rapidly searing
steaks outside on the grill use the
grill gun may result in extreme Grill
Envy from your neighbors and increased
demands for barbecue parties get your
grill gun from Grill Blazers today let
the grilling Adventures begin
grillblazer.com Knowles promo code nulls
for 15 off your order rollblazer.com
Knowles promo code nulls for 15 off
Jesus was a vegetarian do you believe
Jesus was the perfect man without sin
and was God if you're a Christian
undoubtedly you answered yes and white
people have a certain smell to them
every racing culture has peculiarities
from my new King James Version of the
Bible Genesis chapter 1 verse 29 and God
said see I've given you every herb that
yields seed which is on the face of the
Earth and every tree whose fruit yields
seed to you it shall be food so God's
perfect man a disproportionate number of
my friends are very very gay which he
created and the suffering death and
eating flesh only came in after sin so
you believe Jesus is the perfect man and
is also sinless but if you believe he
ate Meat and Fish do you also believe
that he isn't perfect and isn't sinless
would God the creator of all and the
lover of all he created then consume off
the suffering pain and death of the very
things that he created the answer is no
why are we talking about this and why is
it important I think we need to pass a
law Banning people reading two lines out
of the Bible
out of context and that's it two
Corinthians right two Corinthians if
this guy had read more than a line or
two out of the Bible he would have found
answers to his questions was Jesus first
of all if you begin with Jesus was
you're probably on the wrong track
because Jesus if you follow the story
until the end you find out Jesus is
resurrected he lives Our Redeemer Lives
and this is foretold in the Old
Testament one of the first things that
our Lord does when he's resurrected is
grill fish on the beach for his friends
it's right there you don't need to
wonder you don't need to try to abstract
or we know Jesus grills fish for his
friends so there's your answer the
world's a much safer place if we eat the
animals that could eat us the other way
you know that this guy doesn't have a
great grasp on what he's talking about
is one his entire comportment and mode
of speech but the two at the at the end
of the videos and when you think about
other spiritual losters you think okay
here we go we're gonna now he's gonna
tell me about Buddha or something like
that after having read like three words
of the Bible not apparently recognizing
where Christ literally comes into the
scriptures because he says he's citizen
Genesis and in most of the Torah why
doesn't Jesus say this well Jesus is
present obviously from the beginning of
the inspired word he is the Divine logic
of the universe but he literally comes
into the story in the New Testament so
it's a little bit after the Torah and he
answers the question
and makes a lovely meal of fish and we
can have we can have that too no way
eats a delicious meal of meat I like
that as well okay next one he hates
animals human
and that's just back to the matter very
cool speciesist that makes sense he's
the first president in like 145 years to
not have a dog companion
I mean I'm not saying the dog people
that don't like dogs are bad people but
I'm just saying only the dog lovers
would understand that caring towards
animals is a good treat to have in the
humans he's got a lot in his plate
having a dog and that's a lot I mean
we're trying to fight against him that's
the kind of animal abuse that he thinks
should be private information because
those individuals deserve their privacy
who did you vote for I didn't vote
flacus one of the all-time great
interviewers out there she makes one
point that's true which is that we
shouldn't be cruel to animals what are
you doing
that's bad if when we're cruel to
animals but the reason it's bad when
we're cruel to animals is not because
animals have any rights if you're for
human rights but you're not for animal
rights you're a speciesist what is a
speciesist I guess a speciesist
with someone who draws distinctions
between different species
which is true guilty is charged you got
me
of all the isms and the phobias I've
been accused of that one that one Takes
the Cake I am a speciesist I don't want
to be cruel to animals
but only because that would dull my
Humanity only because that would turn me
into a psycho
and and in a way uh probably create in
me or stoken me a an appetite for for
suffering you know a delight inside
that's what like little kids who torture
animals they turn into serial killers so
that's why you do it but it's not
because the animal as a rational Soul or
any rights or anything like that just
because of you okay keep going all right
we're at a pig vigil right now outside
of a slaughterhouse that Slaughters ten
thousand pigs per day we're bearing a
witness to the pigs going in stopping
the trucks giving them water giving them
love and then these people show up they
think it's hilarious to come and set up
a barbecue
right in front of us they just came
across the road as we were bearing
witness to the truck and brought over a
hot dog and offered it to us
if you recognize them give them hell
oh that's great there was some years ago
at Yale The Graduate students went on a
hunger strike Yale graduate students
were some of the highest paid graduate
students anywhere in the world and they
went on a hunger strike because while
they were allowed to unionize they I
think weren't allowed to unionize by
department or something like that so
these these guys go on hunger strike and
the Yale College Republicans decided to
hold a barbecue right next to them
this is giving me serious Vibes of that
kind of a demonstration a really good
demonstration that's great gosh the idea
of ten thousand pigs just being
slaughtered and turned into bacon every
day bacon is good for me
salivating just thinking about it is
that it that's all of them what's my
favorite one
I think my favorite one yet again is the
last video very often it's the last
video I think it's not just because it's
fresh in my mind
but sometimes those are the really
Punchy ones and that was just absolutely
delightful and hilarious and so
charitable of those young men
to offer the poor sweaty climate
activists a tasty hot dog I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
this is better the commissary will
continue to serve horrifying artery
clogging hamburgers
[Applause]